hey guys it's Wednesday I'm Dan I'm Joe
and it's time for games what news no
[Music]
I'll be honest with you guys we are
tentative about giving you constant news
updates on how many people are playing
the hottest game of the minute but
fortnight will just not be ignored well
at least the free battle royale mode a
new graphic posted on fortnight's
official Twitter account has revealed
that 10 million players have flocked to
fortnight's battle royale mode over the
two weeks since it released that
culminates in 244 million four hundred
and ninety four thousand five hundred
and seventy one hours played and a bunch
of other statistics like how many
umbrellas have been earned or how many
traps have been found it seems there's
more than enough love to go around for
battle royale game types though as
player unknowns battlegrounds just hit 2
million concurrent players on Steam so
fortnight doesn't appear to be gouging
the pub G player base at all you guys
are just freely into 100 player
hide-and-seek with guns games right now
pub G is the first game to ever surpass
2 million concurrent and according to
the unofficial stats from Steam DP sales
of the game currently stand at around
15.6 million copies if you've got an EA
or Origin Access subscription then
there's some big games headed your way
for the price of your subscription
you'll probably be surprised to hear
that Mass Effect Andromeda is among the
selection of games you'll have access to
on both Xbox one and PC yes not Mass
Effect Andromeda the one that basically
just came out besides the divisive space
adventure access members will also get
to check out play first trial versions
of Star Wars Battlefront 2 and Need for
Speed payback PA has said that you'll be
able to get into the former before
launch day but haven't specified how
much earlier or for how long you'll have
access those of you on Xbox one will
have a couple of extra things to look
forward to in the coming months
this seems four will be available
through the services play first trial
and dead space 3 is joining the vault if
you don't have a subscription and want
something that's a hundred percent free
DRM free versions of torchlight and
torchlight 2 - awesome RPGs are free
right now on gog.com if you've never
played either
imagine a Diablo s copy G with two niche
graphics where you fish a lot it's great
I'm on the cutting edge of virtual
reality is that right well you know
who's actually on the cutting edge of
virtual reality is the current oculus
connect full conference where we've
already heard a bunch of really
interesting announcements not including
Virtual Boy
first up Respawn Entertainment the
developers of titanfall have announced
they have a super-secret vr project
coming in 2019 before you start
speculating respawned director peter
Hirshman has clearly stated that it's
not related to titanfall or Star Wars
that third-person Star Wars title is
staying under wraps it seems the project
is trying to capture a realistic
first-person combat experience
there's no gameplay or really any
indication of what's going to look like
but you can check out the full teaser
video for yourself right here on games
but also with the conference Facebook
announced two new oculus headsets one of
which doesn't require a PC or smartphone
to function the oculus go headsets
hardware is all built into the unit
itself and will carry a pretty sweet
$200 price tag def kits for the new unit
are set to be sent out in November with
a full release of oculus go in early
2018 the second headset revealed was an
update to project Santa Cruz the
wireless oculus VR headset with built-in
cameras for positional tracking the new
headset will feature full six degrees of
freedoms movement and new controllers
that look pretty similar to the touch
controllers if all this talk of virtual
reality has you contemplating jumping in
you'll be happy to hear oculus announced
of the price of their current headset
the rift has been cut for the new price
of $399 you'll get the headset to senses
to touch controllers and seven games
Lucky's tale medium toy box 12 dead and
buried dragon front and River recall the
new price brings the rift in line with
PS via and it's available right now is
everything we have for you today you
enjoy the rest of your day and we'll be
here tomorrow and Friday for the top 5
news stories of the entire week we hope
to see you then
breaking news it's Wednesday
[Laughter]